[Music]
actually the Spongebob movie sponge on
the run was supposed to be released in
u.s. cinemas in August
however as variety announced a few days
ago the release of the CGI film will be
postponed to the u.s. streaming service
CBS all access the streaming service
will be launched at the beginning of
2021 and will feature spongebob has its
first exclusive film CBS all access
focuses on family friendly entertainment
anyway it will include content from
Nickelodeon Comedy Central MTV and many
more before the release of CBS all
access viewers will also have the
opportunity to watch Sponge up on the
run on Amazon Prime not free of charge
of course in terms of content the movies
are of course again about The Adventures
of the yellow sponge and his friend
Patrick they've left their hometown
Bikini Bottom and are now on their way
to Atlantic City to free SpongeBob's pet
snail Gary from the hands of the evil
King Poseidon with the release of sponge
on the rum the movies the next bigger
movie after trolls world tour scoop and
Artemis Fowl which is not shown in
cinemas an exact start date for CBS all
access is unfortunately not yet known
with a delay of three months James
Cameron's Avatar 2 has finally started
shooting again as before the shooting
break the producers are not stingy with
exclusive footage a few days ago Jon
Landau posted a picture on Instagram
showing a so-called underwater
performance capture according to his own
statement it is a picture from last year
but it's still a really interesting shot
which gives us another look behind the
scenes of all this incredibly
elaborately produced film the picture
shows actor Britton Dalton who will play
the son of Jake and a teary in Avatar 2
to 5 as already known for quite some
time some scenes of the movie will take
place underwater especially the water
creatures of Navi where nothing else
than banshees form the water are in the
center of the attention by the way the
fans don't have to worry about the
punctual cinema release because as the
avatar Twitter account once again
confirmed the sequel will be released on
time on December 17 2021 for quite some
time there have been rumors that the
Walking Dead actor Jeffrey Dean Morgan
would appear as Batman in the upcoming
flesh solo movie however as The
Hollywood Reporter and deadline now
agree Michael Keaton is supposed to
appear as Batman in the flash instead
although there is no official commitment
Warner and Keaton are in an early stage
of negotiations alleged lead has been
leaked that Keaton will not play any
Batman but exactly the same one he
played in Tim Burton's earlier films all
this is supposed to be possible because
the DCE will be changed to a multiverse
from now on Keaton's appearance is far
from being a one-off as the Curran ago
she ation paper apparently also provides
for future roles for the actor similar
to Marvel's Nick Fury Keaton could
therefore take on a kind of mentoring
role or act as a string poor in the
background of course these are all
exciting ideas but of course they
haven't been verified yet so we're so
often in the film business the first
thing to do is to wait until an official
announcement is made by Warner Brothers
the US release of the flash is so far
for the third of June 2022 Colin
Trevorrow has without question shaped
the Jurassic world series into what it
is today with this he seems to have made
an impression on Universal because as
has said in various media reports the
director will soon dedicate himself to
his new project Atlantis he even wrote
the story for this with his colleague
Matt Charman surprisingly however the
aforementioned city of Atlantis as
neither disappeared no sunk but it's a
multicultural civilization hidden from
the rest of the world on a long
forgotten continent the inhabitants of
the empire have their own and quite
sophisticated technology the idea of
Trevor often Sharman will be written by
edge of tomorrow third Dante Hopper in
the near future Universal has already
managed to secure a major personal
commitment for the position of
production designer namely Kevin Jenkins
Jenkins has already worked on the latest
Star Wars trilogy and guardians of the
galaxy and has a lot of experience in
the field of visually stunning
blockbusters of course the release of
Atlantis is still a long way off as
Jurassic world Dominion has to be
released before Trevor off can work on
his newest project this will most likely
be the case from 10th of June 2021 on
last week we reported about the 24 hour
event DC fan dome which is fully
accessible from home so far the rock and
the Suicide Squad team for example have
announced their appearance the
world-famous San Diego comic-con will
have a similar approach as a public
event with thousands of people is still
not possible the so called Comic Con at
home will be accessible worldwide and of
course for free apart from the usual
content panels three of which have been
confirmed so far will prove
variety firstly the u.s. broadcaster AMC
has announced that The Walking Dead will
have its own panel the focus will be on
the tenth season of the series which has
not yet been aired the panel includes
chief cannon officer Scott M Gimple
Shura angela Kang as well as actors
Norman Reedus Jeffrey Dean Morgan and
Alyssa McBride and many more also
represented as the spin of fear The
Walking Dead gang and Gimple will be on
stage together with some actors of the
series the last panel around the zombie
franchise will be booth of The Walking
Dead world beyond the start of the
offshoot had to be postponed also due to
the pandemic so you can be curious about
the presentation of world beyond as the
last official panel of AMC the series
nor I - is planned what sounds like the
name of the new born of Elon Musk is a
horror series with actors Zachary Quinto
again you can expect an appearance of
the executive producer and the cast what
do you think about the comic-con offer
can you imagine to be part of such an
event like front of the screen or is
that out of the question for you write
it down in the comments
[Music]